[Music]
see
[Music]
dialing 16 numbers to talk to someone
you realize it's like
2 a.m in paris sure but you're the one
sleeping with the shades open to a fully
lit
eiffel tower in parisian music playing
at full volume
so i'm pretty sure your forced
geographical establishing cues
contradict your desire to get a good
night's sleep
you and i were in this dixieland van i
believe those are just called land bands
now jeremy
well this is just poor road construction
right here they have completely
destroyed this road in a way that makes
it unpassable and yet have stationed the
barriers directly at the site instead of
the turn-off that leads to the road and
then they put traffic cones so that all
these people that need to turn around to
get out of here can't even move
there will be no escape also how and why
did they leave this sidewalk
intact while clearly digging up both
sides of it also also why isn't scooter
couple here just taking the sidewalk out
of this mess immediately
how did candace know her mother had
arrived seconds ago mom was stuck in
traffic so it's not like she was
expected
backyard now please my park in the road
when you have a driveway i would have
been home sooner but it took me an hour
to drive around the road construction in
the neighborhood
an hour it took you literally 13 seconds
to go from here
to here so what exactly are you hiding
linda flynn fletcher
do you mind we have a visual gag going
on here i'm not sure how many walls
phineas is breaking here but him being
aware of a forced lower third generic
non-promotion is some next level meta
somehow phineas and ferb is turning into
the deadpool of disney animation and i'm
not sure that's as good of a thing as
you think it is
also lower thirds
okay fine i guess we should take a sent
off for all the fun running gags this
show does like this doofenshmirtz evil
jingle
so you know what we're gonna do today
we're giving a sin off and hoping a bird
doesn't run into it
we're expecting a slight delay for our
arrival in tokyo that's always something
turbulence headwind giant jump roping
robots
a robot that wasn't mentioned by the
pilot so how would he know that it was
hanging from the back of the plane
also show seems to be indicating that
this robot got caught on this plane
while jumping rope this means that
either the plane dipped its altitude to
basically ground level or this robot
leaped about 35
000 feet into the air and now i'm the
jerk that has to point out the
impossibility of this in a cartoon
featuring a giant sentient robot that
jumps rope
also also wouldn't that cause the plane
to immediately crash and wouldn't that
mean the show is over and i can go back
to doing nothing he says as he
dramatically crosses his fingers
i'm also packing this book of puns
getting your puns from a book also how
do you write a pun book and not give it
a pun name
what about punny side up or born to pun
or an all military pun book called the
puns of navagrone
paris french girls and jeremy
narrating your dreams in your sleep i'm
expecting an alarm to go off because the
clock just made a noise but apparently
this clock is designed to beep as the
minutes tick on who the
makes a clock like that or who sleeps to
a clock that beeps every minute
stacy if you're gonna dial a phone
number that fast just use the quick dial
feature
press one button take a [ __ ] breath
and ice your sprained button mashing
fingers
also stacy answered that phone instantly
she appears to be sleepy but the moment
candace says her name she is not only
awake but also sitting up and instantly
ready to get on with her day
so you built the statue of liberty no oh
wow that is weird
and impossible it can't be done there's
only 24 hours in a day and that's that i
mean the delivery could use some work
but sure buford would be excellent at tv
sense you see buford if you define the
date and phineas would be excellent at
the tv since comments section
yeah nothing's impossible if you believe
you can do it i'm imagining a child
watching this show and thinking
i believe i can get good grades attend
college feed myself
and keep my place clean while also never
leaving the couch because one more round
of fall guys isn't going to play itself
and now their grades are trashed they're
in debt and still living in their
parents basement all because phineas is
a bold-faced liar
and now we know why phineas is so
ambivalent to danger as he has been
abandoned by adults on the rear
of a bike that is absolutely not
designed for tiny babies you've got to
give
everyone their bikes back mine was the
one with the unusually large front wheel
oh a sudden appearance of a strange man
amidst a group of children who are
gathered in a private backyard
someone can call the police or not
phineas what are you doing
you're putting your entire world view on
the line and for what twitter
clay aiken yeah i hired a stunt singer
what do you think i think your clay
aiken reference is firmly trapped in the
year 2003 even though this
aired in 2010. i also think you have too
much money for a kid aren't you a little
young to be able to hire an american
idol runner-up for a backyard concert
if you agree with buford
that's all it will ever be buford
challenged finney 60 seconds ago so how
would clay know to sing this line
is he improvising this sounds far too
rehearsed to be improvised
given how clean the floor appears to be
we know that it's often swept or mopped
at what point does someone wonder why
perry's bed is stuck in its position
on the floor or that it flips around
thanks to a hole in the floor
kind of weird though that he took the
time to cut each letter out of a
magazine
except he didn't many of these segments
have multiple letters including the
entire urkov section down here what word
is that even from that isn't the word
undercover an alcoholic witch's group
called the beer coven
even that has another e that could have
been used wait is it super covid
is this a message to the future also
this four
doesn't even appear to be cut out of
anything i can't believe you brought
work with me
i can't believe they allow humans on the
conveyor belts do you know how
long i've wanted to ride that thing i
don't know something tells me that
whoever installed the gutter system on
this house may have been tragically
inexperienced
you want to come too well i get one
carry on all right
carry on then going along with a
kidnapping bully you're going to paris
france fa rance stacy they're going to
paris where jeremy is
you promised your mom you keep your
brothers out of trouble missing jeremy
so much that you don't care who you
might hurt
if you prick me do i not bleed sorry
what were we talking about again
earlier not marshall mathers was taped
up in a seated position but now he's
standing sure they may have had time to
retape him in a different position but
that's just wasting quality duct tape
man tokyo's a fun town i have no idea
what just happened
me either but i'm uncomfortable and now
researching is phineas and ferb
accidentally racist
oh they got it they caught her uh-huh
sure still going when she survives this
vanessa has been launched off the side
of a building that looks like this
which looks nothing like this even perry
the platypus is not immune for me please
occasionally look the direction you are
driving sin
this is the room where we test the
stretching this is the room where we
test the
bounce honestly by those two lines i'm
still not sure if you're running a
rubber factory or a torture palace so
i'm still a bit on edge can we borrow
one of these and by borrow he means take
destroy and never return here's your
parachute goggles and oxygen mask maybe
those goggles would have been a good
idea before now considering the lack of
flight protection would leave your eyes
to be tiny stones devoid of all moisture
so how'd it go well there was some more
breaking of the laws of physics a few
more they survived this is and a general
continued meta-awareness of the
ridiculousness as an attempt to forgive
it all
so i'm gonna say it went sinningly
[Music]
but somehow they are stopping how else
could they keep getting these costumes
they clearly didn't pack
i assume this song is only called
bouncing around the world because
bouncing around the vaguely problematic
stereotypes was already taken
we're all out of rubber bands but the
good news is we're gonna crash into
paris
how is that good news better question
how does he know that they just knocked
into the atomium in belgium and paris is
about 200 miles away
how does he know anything will work
vanessa you rented a scooter
uh yeah rented grand theft scooter
it's okay i speak english yes i speak
english
americans rob apparently had his bike
stolen and posted this sign in paris and
this one in china
imagine being dedicated enough to
finding your lost bike to post signs
around
the entire globe but still apathetic
enough to not even include a phone
number
[Music]
i think it's worth pointing out that
both of the main female characters in
this episode spent their entire
storyline pining for oblivious dudes as
if all that matters for women is
validation by being part of a romantic
relationship i'm not saying it's sexist
i'm just saying it's extremely sexist
no he's my dad and i shouldn't blame him
for being busy it's just that
he always seems to put his work ahead of
me i just don't know what to do
oh yeah and the third female lead is
defined by her daddy issues
so basically the definition of being a
woman in this episode is to desperately
seek your validation in a man
that said i'm getting my tweezers back
from carl changing your appearance
because of one eyebrow critic
i thought you know the two of you a boy
a girl
alone in the city of love good gravy
mother of dragons there are children
watching
also it says something about how
ridiculous this show is that i actually
thought they had decided to go full
looney tunes and that isabella would
just grow a new head back instead of the
craziness happens but it was just
someone's imagination cliche so here's
the sin for being ridiculous enough that
i would believe this in an extra sin for
doing the cliche anyway like when you
see your teacher at the grocery store
weird or like when someone you've known
for a long time starts wearing a cowboy
hat weird or when your teacher wears a
cowboy hat while riding a bull at the
bar
weird i can keep going we haven't even
breached my top 16 and a half weird
things list
look at all the things you've done
summer belongs to you
roll some herschels jeremy you said the
g
word wait i missed it and really don't
want to rewind
was it gorilla gastrointestinal
geriatric gross grain
galactic gauntlet germaphobe geode
gigantic
gorgonzola grotesque it was gum wasn't
it you do
realize that you're stranded on this
island too right i don't care i'm
winning
[Laughter]
politics look a sponge and a starfish
there's gotta be something we can make
out of this with those ingredients you'd
think you might be able to make a
different ridiculous animated show but
you'd be missing the key ingredient
drugs lots of drugs
i get a window seat it's it's a paper
airplane
oh no road construction they have dug a
massive trench in the middle of a
neighborhood and i think this goes far
beyond
road construction and lands firmly in
the neighborhood planning gone terribly
wrong category what is below ground
that far beneath the surface stretching
several blocks that demands this type of
attention
also this trench is so deep that they've
hung a porta-potty out over the ledge
because nobody will care that human
waste will spill out of the bottom down
into the abyss below
as these kids ride their bikes down this
road towards a ramp with a sun setting
in the distance i'm guessing we're about
to see an e.t homage
if we do i'm sending it for the
predictability if we don't i'm sending
it for not paying homage to one of the
greatest moments in film history so what
i'm saying is that i don't even have to
see how this ends to know i'm sinning it
and now you know how the sin sausage is
made
[Music]
but the sun already set so as the show
indulges in yet another musical number
this time of the royal commercials
variety i have to ask how is the
entirety of this cast a trumpet prodigy
and how with no preparation did they
pull this song out of their brass
why are this person's shoes stuck to the
bottom of their feet i bet they have
those old sandals that have morphed to
their foot shape and contain years of
sweat and then they stepped in a puddle
and the liquid turned to that strange
foot funk goo and rather than take them
off clean them and air them out they
just wore them around and now they are
one with their sandals
you came back early jeremy saw candace
earlier in the day and grabbed an
immediate flight from paris to the
tri-state area and arrived within
hours minutes if it was phineas or ferb
i'd have to roll my eyes and shrug
because the bar has been set and their
inexplicable shenanigans are legendary
but a normal average jeremy joe
nope i'm a synon this musical number
ends with shots from completely
unrelated episodes and i really would
have thought cindy would have seen that
oh there you are cine
all this time i've been underneath paris
there's this proud moment in every
content creator's life when their
creative offspring head out on their own
channel adventures and don't need papa
cinemasins anymore well
that don't you forget we're only
starting to get your ass back over to
cinemasins before dark
damn kids
and what's more our best you can't do it
you bet us you're pretty crazy
but i can't turn down free money you got
a bit
coincidence i think not in paris and
surrounded by french girls i'm no fool
stacey i've seen the oil paintings
jack i want you to draw me like one of
your french girls well
say hi to jeremy for me say hi to your
mother for me there's a man out there
i don't know what's going on here please
look in the name
i don't know ferb i know he's my dad and
i shouldn't blame him for being busy
[Music]
yes yes yes no no no
yes yes yes